[Music]
Prince Harry and Megan Marco spotted for
the first time as newlyweds here's the
Duke and Duchess of Sussex looking to
cool on Monday cruising around London in
casual clothes and Sonny's just two days
after their royal wedding at Windsor
Castle et has learned the couple is set
to make their first official post
wedding appearance on Tuesday at Prince
Charles's 70th birthday party at
Buckingham Palace on their big day
Harry's father escorted his now
daughter-in-law down the aisle during
Saturday's ceremony she thanked the
royal family for welcoming her so warmly
into the fold and she said an especially
big thank you to Prince Charles who of
course stepped in at the 11th hour and
walked her down the aisle
Merkel's praise didn't stop there at the
couples evening reception Megan broke
tradition once again toasting to her mom
Doria Raglan I do know that she thanks
her mother not just for being there
today but for being there for her entire
life
and I'm not sure what she said if
anything about Thomas Markel